tous les dix ans un basket envoyé dans
l'espace léopold eyharts né à biarritz a
remis ça en 2008 mais en 2018 en est
fini pour lui le voyage est alors
effectuée par un gâteau basque
mais pourquoi donc envoyé des plats ou
des objets dans l'espace déjà en 1971
les cosmonautes d'apollo 15 sont
équipées de clubs de golf
une fois leur mission remplie ils ont pu
jouer quelques minutes sur la lune mais
la conquête de l'espace est avant tout
une compétition internationale
les cosmonautes d'apollo 15 ont donc
aussi embarquer un autre objet de
communication celui là à la gloire des
états unis j'ai la tâche agréable
d'estampiller ici pour la première fois
sur la lune
un timbre qui est un nouveau timbre
heureusement qu'il était collé d'avancé
car sinon je ne sais pas très bien comme
j'aurais plus peur
en 1982 c'est au tour de la france de
crâne et dans l'espace et l'équipage
pour être l miniature a mené par le
spationaute français comme cadeau à ses
camarades de l'espace à tout ça paraît
anecdotique mais en 1972 aborde pioneer
10 voici un objet d'intérêt scientifique
une plaque d'or qui pourrait servir à
communiquer avec les extraterrestres
sur ses flancs pioneer 10 ans portait
une plaque en or sur laquelle était
grave et les informations élémentaires
relatives à notre planète sa position
astronomique ses habitants la
probabilité de découverte par des
extraterrestres est proche de zéro une
bouteille jetée dans la mer
interstellaire
[Musique]